there's nothing wrong with hierarchy you
mean human beings are naturally
hierarchical animals we're constantly
organizing ourselves into hierarchies
you know you you sit in the meeting you
adjudge who's more senior who's the
alpha there's nothing wrong with that
but the problem is is the responsibility
that goes with being an influencer or an
alpha or a leader which is you know
biologically anthropologically
our leaders are supposed to look after
us you know it's like a parent right um
and so uh um
though people want the perks
of influence or they want the money they
want the fame they want the recognition
the problem is is what are you willing
to give back
are you doing these things just for
yourself you're doing these things i get
this question all the time you know hey
simon i want to be a public speaker how
do i get into the industry and my
question is what's your message well i
don't know yet so
so why do you want to be a public
speaker like i i never wanted to be a
public speaker by the way i still don't
want to be a public speaker
what i want to do is spread a message
something that i desperately believe in
and so
you know there used to be a time where
people got famous because of their
contribution you were uh a a political
leader or you were a scientist or you
you know you climbed mount everest like
we we admired you and you got your alpha
status you became sort of an influencer
because of your contribution to
something
uh
and now we live in a world where you can
become an influencer with no
contribution whatsoever you can hack the
system get more followers all the rest
of it um
even entertainers entertain us
and so you know the question is why do
you want to be an influencer great you
want to be an influencer why do you want
to be an influencer what is so important
that you're willing to sacrifice all
kinds of things to do something for
someone else and you choose to use
youtube or whatever you know uh
uh medium to spread your message and i
think you have to know what you stand
for and you have to know why you're
going into it otherwise it's totally a
selfish pursuit and you may have some
short-term success but eventually we'll
move on to the next shiny object if you
wanna have lasting influence if you
wanna
maintain the capacity to inspire people
you have to stand for something
you